LinkedIn is the social network most commonly used by professionals
We're always among the best apps on Google Play
I am Bradypta Dash
I am the Director of Engineering at LinkedIn
And its leading applications
We got over a million comments
We always get 4 stars or higher
Our users appreciate the stability of the application
And its role in highlighting the strengths of their professional portfolio
I'm Drew Hani
I work on LinkedIn's core Android architecture team
My team is responsible for Android app performance
We are responsible for the app versions on Google Play
And on testing the application or building designs
One of the tools that excited my team
Is an APK parser tool
Because we spend most of the time monitoring the size of the app
Some experience was required
To see what determines the size of the application
But with the APK parser tool available
We were able to increase the knowledge of the team as a whole
Linkdein was one of the pioneers in the adoption of Gradle
The Gradle adoption in Android was very convenient for us
Because we share a lot of plug-ins that we've released
We can get consistent versions across software development machines and version service
We especially benefited from the Lint system
Which contains a lot of integrated tests for common problems
We really appreciate our ability
To write and customize Lint tests
For LinkedIn specific internal libraries
Many developers are checking code base
One of the things that facilitates the admission of a new person
The pattern of symbols is constant across each code base
Android Studio lets us select a custom icon style
Each software developer can add it
And automatically get code format with LinkedIn style
And one of the things we also benefit from
Is that this Statute is open
Where comments can not be accepted only
Which was given to the developer forum
But can also be acted upon
My team became over the past two years
Much faster, and more flexible
Making it easier and faster to encode in Android Studio.